Jim just down that one
it's not shamanucci
he done this one
good quietly person will kick me and
punch me punch me to death
he can't kick me and punch punch okay
ready
he's not gonna do anything
hopefully
so uh you need to be a
hey out the way out the way
quick turn right try with the hips
foreign
there is one other
when you're really busy
wrong technique
this is when you're quick
when you're quick
helpful
hopefully he won't kick you
but that's more fun
hey
we'll try again hey
please try hey
ah
we've done this
elbows down
if you do this incorrect I'll Attack
just to put your
if he puts his elbows here
I can throw him down
okay so the power might strike you have
to give people credit they're not gonna
just uh you know we're looking at uh
well I don't know who is Joe public well
we're looking at um martial artists
against martial artists
ah
and that's powerful enough
and he stops he's family so there is an
incorrect way so if the arms are up I
this is okay the arms are up
like this I can use him like a
springboard but throw him away
so he has to
ah arms down this way you you cut him
down you turn him to his phone
foreign
this is a keyhole
this is a basic
last time I was here I'm not gonna move
last time I was here I done
kihan he strikes my temple
hey I go off all right I strike his
Temple but that put my elbows down I've
left that with you uh to try and
throughout the year you make an
adjustment
you turn
then you go down
this is what you should have been left
with uh the end of last year when I came
this year ah I put some movement into it
this is the
this is the stage you're developing up
to so elbows must be kept down